coming in at move seven yeah we're
coming in uh move seven not too much has
happened it is the catalan opening and
it is a quite a well-known variation of
the catalan uh this is something that
magnus played during his world
championship match against the uganda
pomnicie he prepared it especially for
that match i think pretty much all the
world champions have played the catalan
opening
um yeah it's just so solid for white
it's very hard to get active as black
it's very hard to create winning chances
as black and
i think that favors carlson if we talk
about styles farouza wants to be active
it's very hard to do that against this
opening however furuja has gone greedy
and grabbed a pawn so temporarily in the
current position that we're looking at
black is a pawn up
and uh magnus he ends up choosing one of
the older main moves
this bishop coming out
there are
many many options on this last move for
white
roger defends the pin
and this is just a very solid pawn push
white's getting ready to move his queen
to the square that this pawn previously
sat on white's rook next to his king
will slide across white's going to try
and play in the center he's not
necessarily going to try and win that
black extra pawn on c4 any time soon
he's just getting his pieces ready and
this is still
a theory as far as i know yep theory it
is still very much theory late last game
that was played was actually played
between uh
two female players avantika against
kastanyak and that was a win for
castanek but that was
if i know it was a rapid blitz match
and uh questioning was which color she
was black okay so win for black in that
game now the dark square bishops are
coming off uh off the board
black recaptures with his knight
and we do have a draw in game three
prague duda that means prague in ten
minutes game four black pieces has to
win that game to take it to toy breaks
he can uh most hope for two points today
prague he cannot take all three points
duda on fire winning against magnus
yesterday a favorite now to win his
match against prague
is anyone else kind of hoping that hands
i mean hands is down to the last game
now they're one and a half full against
tyronian i'm kind of hoping that you
know hands gets something
you know from from today's because you
know
it's not just about his character but
he's been playing some great chess i
mean like he's been winning a lot of
games but losing the matches so he
deserves to be able to afford to pay
that uber food bill definitely he needs
that money he needs to get his lobster
in tonight come on hands just draw it
and take it to thai race oh blitz with
hans nemo that must be a lot of fun yeah
so
it would be nice actually to see hans
get off the scoreboard because
absolutely like simon said you know
you know his his play is so much better
than the score and it's just somehow
that's kind of unfortunate result of the
kind of match situation things haven't
been going his way
and magnus jumping in with his knight
and uh well faruja playing very quickly
which suggests that he's still in within
his prep
preparation and uh
defending the pawn and magnus
challenging that pawn on c4 yeah so now
it's a proper pawn sacrifice magnus
doesn't want to regain his pawn he's
happy after this pawn exchange to just
play the position
and uh i guess black will castle black
will try to get developed the
compensation that magnus will have as
white is firstly white's light squared
bishop just a fantastic piece also some
dark square holes in the black camp um
especially the c5 square maybe ripe for
a white night later on
but this is ambitious i was going to say
as well the catalan opening it's very
good choice in general it's just one of
the best openings out there but magnus
will know that farouza would have
prepared
hundreds of hours for this uh in
preparation for the candidates
tournament so you're kind of playing
into an area that your opponent can
predict
but it is objectively a correct opening
so it's kind of uh
yes
and i have an interesting uh point
actually in my database i have a game
from 2017 between maxod lulu
against ali reza farouja ah so
maybe magnus is aware of that game in
that particular game farouza actually
picked up the sea pawn and challenged
the center by playing c5
okay his mouse if we're looking at
ferrus
screen right now his mouse his cursor
was hovering over that c5 square
um normally though you would pick up the
pawn and drag it to that square so maybe
that doesn't indicate that he's going to
play that move how did that game end up
jovanka ended
you don't want me to try pronouncing
because it would be horrendous but um
yeah great guy
fantastic player yeah
now the iranian number one now that
ferugia has moved from iran to france
very strong but yeah i struggle a lot
with pronouncing any names but
especially that one
but i i have to say the catalan opening
i mean
the more i'm looking at the more i'm
thinking i've got to learn this you know
i've got to play the catalan
because you know it just seems like you
often sack a pawn you often get
compensation that's right up my street
it's very it's very fashionable now um
what's the best way of learning i mean
chess bullet must have a course on it do
you guys know i don't know which course
they got yeah they have a course um i
think it's
by an indian grand master and it's an
indian grand master i want to say so
there a man but i don't know
might not be
right i'll have to look it up yeah
okay well that's that i'll look that up
later so training
course on the catalan i need to i need
to go and get that course after this
definitely yeah it's an interesting game
this one and game three with duda and
prague ended in a draw let's hear from
the two players after that game
prior gay was uh drawing this game how
would you summarize i think i had great
chances in this game but
yeah
i just missed it at some point
what is your feeling before the last one
not great but i'll drive members good
luck
it's been a very interesting day today
answer stuff you've had special chances
in the second game how did you feel
after that one
yeah it's too interesting uh to be
honest um no i mean the second game was
a disaster i
kind of
blacked out
at the end and
um also i i think i was winning by force
later on but even this queen in the game
is completely winning okay
the thing is i
just was missing a lot of stuff like a
lot of checks and
at the very end i um
put the queen on the
g5 it was completely stupid but i was
afraid because i was earlier on giving
some random checks and was afraid not to
blunder
freehold
so um
yeah i i i mean it was disastrous
because otherwise the match would be
almost over but
um in this game i was worse but after f5
i had a feeling it's it's going to be
okay because i was getting some activity
and it wasn't it wasn't trivial to
for him to convert
you've been playing very good in the
start of your matches now you need a
draw in the last one based on previous
experience will you try to play a little
more aggressive now
uh
i think he will play aggressively so i
will just you know
hopefully cope with that
good luck thanks
bad experience for duda yesterday he won
the first two games against magnus and
then lost the two next one so we went to
tie breaks where he eventually did win
and magnus here he is uh fighting in
game four
to win this match and take all three
points the bar is now slightly over to
his side
yeah and for magnus fans that's
generally a positive magnus is after all
a pawn down and if the evaluation bar
thinks that you're doing quite well
despite being upon down
it tends to mean you have a pretty good
position and uh magnus just improving
his queen there
i just like the control that he has on
the position so despite black's extra
pawn
black's position full of holes remember
maybe we can jump in just to show
what the plans might be for either side
over the coming coming moves
so the main compensation white has for
the pawn is that he has a beautiful
outpost for his knight
and uh he could use this over the next
couple of moves for example if black
takes a timeout the white knight might
jump in attacking this bishop keeping an
eye on this pawn in the corner i just
don't see how black is ever really going
to challenge this piece also white does
have this kind of majority in the center
at some point you might consider pushing
forward you don't want to rush this your
position might become a bit loose but
later on you have the kind of lever the
key to open up the center kicking away
black's knight
parousia now brings his queen across
just to defend his bishop there was
after all a pin along this diagonal and
uh magnus i'm expecting him over the
next few moves to bring his rook across
line it up with a black queen
maybe jump his knight in
okay he jumps in immediately and yeah
it's just strategic compensation long
term black sex report is this one after
all and it's not easy to push uh even
the square in front of it this a5 square
is controlled by white and there we go
the bishop moves and magnus says i'm
going to create some pressure
ah this just looks so beautiful for
white if white had an extra pawn uh well
if it wasn't a pawn down then you would
say strategically winning for white
it's just black having that one pawn to
cling on to is that enough
what do you guys think would you take
the pawn or would you take the position
essentially
i i would take the position i mean this
looks like a great uh
game for whites you know such natural
moves such pressure i mean what is black
gonna do i mean black doesn't even have
an active plan and if black is just
simply reduced to like
twiddling around with pieces making
small moves here and there it just feels
like white has the
luxury of just building
and that's so so difficult i guess black
could maybe play for bringing his rook
to the center eventually breaking out
with this pawn uh black could maybe aim
to at some point move this night out the
way i'm not sure whether you can do it
safely right now for example move out
the way try to trade off these bishops
if that can exchange off a few pieces
maybe at some point try and trade off
this knight as well
some hope for black but
it feels very loose
it is a magnus type of position as well
especially kind of
post 2019 magnus who likes to sacrifice
pawns here and there
um yeah inspired by daniel dubois of
course magnus loves to give up those
pawns as kind of dominance positionally
yeah it's tough to call
yeah i think farusha won't be very happy
either i mean we're talking about magnus
and
all his side but you've got to think
farouza i mean he he likes having the
initiative right and uh here he's he's
got to defend and i don't think he
really that's that's an area of his game
he's he's not as keen on
um being a pawn up and defending he'd
much rather be on the white side of this
i mean it's not terrible yet you do have
the extra pawn and if something goes
wrong that extra pawn will count later
on and i expect a lot of players
would take the black side here but
practically speaking it's just easier
for white to play this position and
that's a big bonus and we now see this
rook the eight move black potentially
trying to get active right but that pawn
break in the middle after that move
whoops not two squares just one square
and uh yeah it's always uncomfortable
for the opponent if your rook
stares down at queen
here we have this standoff between the
black rook and the white queen still
some stuff in between but likewise the
white rook and the black queen both
sides feeling a bit uncomfortable i
wouldn't be surprised if magnus here
just moves moves this piece out of the
way just to prevent any tricks
minus thinking now for 30 seconds uh
this is a
massive game in the tournament if minus
wins this game
it's so likely he will win the
tournament right yeah i mean especially
if prague doesn't make that comeback
magnus will wait could he win it here
he could win it now
in this game right he's one point ahead
of prague if he gets three points for
the match win he'll be four points ahead
if prague loses
and
there we go magnus could win this
tournament in this round yeah that's
true
and the resurrection will be five
yeah i mean it was so bunched up it was
so close we didn't even consider this no
that's true
especially after you lost the first game
magnus carlsen but uh yeah he could
start the party early
with a win in this game yep
yeah definitely i mean and that's
looking quite possible i mean we'll have
to kind of keep an eye on prague's game
as well won't we just to see
how that goes because prague needs to
get a win to you know
keep in touch with magnus at the moment
yeah
talking of a magnus window i don't
really like this decision he's gone for
he's trading off a bunch of minor pieces
and black was a bit cramped so normally
when you have more space if your
opponent is struggling
to kind of find squares for the pieces
exchanging things off
not necessarily a good idea
now black's extra pawn might become a
factor
yeah i'm not so sure about what magnus
is doing to be honest i mean it still
looks very nice very pleasant not in
trouble with white of course but
uh in terms of trying to win
black i think ferruga will be very happy
that he's managed to make those
exchanges especially the light squared
bishops
so the tension might go on we might not
see magnus win
the tournament in this game yeah for the
excitement in the tournament we are
actually now hoping magnus cross and
will not win this game but how
impressive it will be if he does and
takes all three points in this match and
takes the tournament victory wow
impressive stuff it is already thinking
now let's go back to
miami so many fans in the building there
today
guys we're outside the playing arena and
as you can see it's not just chess
inside but even right here we've got
games on our spectators are having a fun
time here and we're joined by a very
special guest it's women grandmaster
yanya who's joining us hey hello how are
you everybody
jana it's so nice to have you here with
us now jana is from miami and she runs a
chess club tell us a bit about the chess
scene in miami
okay we try to
have more people playing chess and i
like to all the kids try to learn
because it's really good for our kids
then it's my goal to
grow up the chess in miami and then this
tournament is a really really nice
marketing for chess here i was actually
going to ask you what does it mean to
have all these top players here how
inspiring is it for the kids at the club
oh my god this is a good inspiration for
us and have this big tournament here
with all the players is like a partial
like a big chess party here
thank you so much
indeed it is a celebration of chess here
in miami this weekend
fantastic maybe the next world chess
champion maybe not the next but a future
world chess champion we'll be from miami
we also yesterday talked about the
critical thinking movie based on a miami
high school chess team so chess is big
in miami and
magnus carlsen is right now fighting not
only to win the game and the match
also the tournament if he wins this game
and prague does not win the game that
just started for him against duda game
four
it's trouble for hans niemann as well he
has tied with levon aronian before game
four and the bar just shot up
for levon in this game for we are hoping
niemann will stack up some points he is
still on zero points but it's looking
hard right now live on what a player
such a strong
american player yeah it's looking bad
for hans niemann and here magnus is
doing magnus things so you know just
improving doing simon things science oh
sorry alares of russia doing silent
things
i was thinking about harry
a little little use of harry there yeah
no i i just like the way that magnus is
just uh relocating his pieces just to
apply pressure to a different point the
a6
born and it's so nice to see tanya in
miami with all the support and we are
asking everyone at home you know for
selfie competition how are you cheering
for your favorite player and ahmed said
well they're cheering from budapest
and uh take a look at this there's a lot
of chess fans in budapest
and there we go a big hello to you ahmad
and
like a watch party i know it's super
cool and thomas lehmann says go magnus
amazing games and sends us all the best
wishes
and yeah thank you everyone for sending
in your selfies and keep them coming
show us how you're cheering for your
favorite player and remember to tweet us
using the hashtag chesschamps and
especially if it's feruxa or prague they
need
the energy from around the world right
now mangus carlson if he wins this game
he'll win the tournament if prank does
not win his next game
drama happening in miami
yeah and ivanka you mentioned that
phrase magnus things and this is kind of
classic magnus he's just
regained his pawn now it's level
material again after white recaptures
this rook he's going into an endgame
where he has a strategic advantage
where there's
pretty much no risk
i mean is farouza just going to lose a
pawn
that white knight is just beautiful the
black knight looking pretty good as well
but having less influence
farouza needs something active and
something soon because otherwise he's
just gonna walk into this bind where
magnus is just gonna turn the screw
torture him forever also look at the
clock times five and a half extra
minutes for magnus right now
despite the evaluation by it just feels
like it's all gone in white's favor
uh the last few moves the whole game so
far
how can black fight back
we can't give up hope for ferugia for
russia as well he'll be looking for
positives in his position
it just feels like he's been
outmaneuvered he's lost his pawn back i
guess the big issue is uh do you suffer
and just take the queen or should you
try to
break out and move the queen and hope
for some more active
adventures further along down the line
but okay he's gone for the queen trade
and uh it does feel like magnus can
simply now start to grind and i'm gonna
hand it over to our chicken i was gonna
say grinder
yeah i grind master
okay um but yeah i mean it's just that
type of position where white can sit on
it forever there's zero risk
when you talk about grinding an end game
you want to remove all the risk from the
position
you want to improve your pieces step by
step magnus has a pretty good knight
right now it doesn't need to retreat it
yet it has a nice outpost later why it's
rook perfect the king
is the piece that's uh first to be
improved black's king i guess is going
to do the same gonna sense realise
itself and then it's just about when to
kind of pull the trigger when to start
advancing white's pawns maybe on the
right side of the wall just to gain a
bit of space for the end game
maybe you kick back black knight in the
center with a pawn
it's just kind of step by steps all
these small mini plans
we filmed one video myself and magnus
about accumulating small advantages and
here he's accumulated a few advantages
already better pawn structure with white
especially in the center of the board
he's got a better minor piece a better
rook
and he just needs something a bit more
concrete now so
whether that's the way
or whether it's tactics
i mean the way you've described it david
i mean if i had this position against
you
with the black pieces
you know what i'd do
sorry time i'd resign
i mean it okay it's not that bad but it
is pretty grim and i think everything
you mentioned there makes a lot of sense
i mean it's that idea of creating two
weaknesses though which i think is very
important if people are looking at this
position and they're thinking how how do
i actually improve this well you want to
tie your opponent down to one weakness i
think it's quite clear what that is this
is backwards pawn there and then you
want to try to create another weakness
somewhere else i mean black is kind of
threatening to guard that weakness at
the moment but okay you can see magnus
now trying to create um you know a
weakness somewhere else and he can move
his knight now to keep that pawn tied
down and then i love your idea of trying
to advance on the king side that's where
you want to get the second weakness i
feel use your pawns to create some
weaknesses once you've got the two
weaknesses your opponent becomes
well their defenses are too stretched
right so this this seems like a very
very nice way to play and i really don't
i i think magnus has got very good
chances of winning this really good
chances
especially with five extra minutes on
the clock especially because furuga
hates these types of positions in
general
um as magnus i would probably just move
the white king to the side and then
decide which one uh to push i mean in an
ideal world this girl gang the mean
girls here
will have five members
and uh for example here you can start
pushing everything forward and then
decide later what to do with them i'm
not sure what
these pawns are doing but they look nice
at least
and this is the type of thing where you
just don't want to commit yet you want
to grind you want to kind of make your
opponent crack under the pressure
and uh it's just difficult for example
in a position like this it's difficult
for black to activate his rook um you
can't really activate it now because
white just steps back and will win a
pawn
if you defend this pawn
with your king you're always walking
into potential checks later on white
will save this one for later
this square is well not safe this is a
beautiful outpost for white tonight
anyway white would love to occupy the
open file with this rook later
and uh
yeah white if black is stuck for plans
why not just kind of shuffle the king
across
protect your pawn in the center of the
board another idea that i wouldn't be
surprised from magnus would be to kind
of push one of these pawns but it's not
clear yet which one you want to push and
in what order
i mean the position actually the way
that you've kind of made it seem seems
like it's quite desperate for black
is now the time if black were to get
okay so he retreats the knight to attack
the pawn the king has to move over i
mean is black looking at making like
desperado moves like pushing the f pawn
forward just a challenge in the center
just to give the knight something to do
yeah um maybe i mean that's why not
right now anymore but uh i would have
loved to put the king on this square
partly to defend the spawn which is
undefended but also just to be able to
kind of maintain the integrity of
white's central pawns but magnus he's
being a bit more direct this is where we
had some kind of
back and forth debates in our
grind like a grandmaster course about
when to go for it whether to be really
direct if you have the option uh magnus
dropped his knight back and gave a check
to the black king forcing the black king
back and
would you say magnus is more direct than
you david yes obviously after doing that
course with him yeah um must be very
interesting you know to work with a
world champion on anything but you're
more patient build up than than bagness
i mean definitely right it's interesting
i just like you know fight fine do you
think i mean more universal player than
me i think simply he's much more
confident when kind of attacking taking
risks because he trusts his calculation
maybe a bit more than i do yeah um so
even if he goes forward even if it
doesn't work he'll he'll kind of
regroup he'll step back and then he'll
try and grind again
right interesting right yeah
every player has different kind of
preferences right and he did mention in
a few games we analyzed that i was a bit
too patient occasionally right a bit too
sadistic
so i'm expecting magnus at some point
either to bring his rook to the open
file or to centralize his king just
improve all his pieces and still uphill
struggle for ferruccia meanwhile the bar
inching towards pragnanda's side in game
four against duda frank he has to win
that game to take it to tie breaks
magnus currently thinking and we're
going to go back down
to miami chess going on inside the arena
and i guess also outside sweater
it's not only in front of the computer
screens that our chess players are
really really impressing tanya sachdev
she's fresh off a olympiad medal and now
she's playing 10 boards at the same time
with simulation chess here it's uh
just getting started i can see here and
i'm going to ask one of the players here
how do you feel you're doing against
tanya so far i think i'm doing really
good this is just a beginning but let's
see
antonio she is definitely trying to keep
her focus here while at the same time
hearing that i'm talking about her so we
shall see it's it's the birthday
woah woman tanya sachdev playing against
half the room right now
go tanya that's intense playing uh that
many games at the same time yeah
i mean i've never celebrated my birthday
let's say you played that much chess
but yeah tanya she's been in great form
lately both at the board and in the
commentary of course and uh yeah i mean
it's going to be an honour for those
players to play against her um she'll
hope for some birthday gifts though
she'll want to win those games
she's a competitive she's a winner yeah
what is the biggest number of
simultaneous games you've ever played oh
i once played around 60 but it took 60.
it took
hours and hours yeah i think in general
you want to play about 20 something at
the same time but i took part in this
kind of
record attempt to play
it was a bunch of grandmasters i think
10 of us and we were all playing as many
games as possible i think it took me
four and a half hours or so oh wow i did
lose a few so
wow no wonder it's tiring yeah that's
intense and uh what's going on in the
arena as well it's tense alureza is he
now fighting for his life in this game
or what's the situation for him yeah um
as simon mentioned as well black is
solid enough for now um he only does
have that one big weakness on the c6
square and also he does have ideas of
trading off pieces
and
okay what's happening here magnus has
just traded off a set of knights frugia
is indeed fighting for his life but
if he fights successfully over the next
few moves he could just eliminate all
the danger immediately and okay magnus
oh
magnus looked up
and he's reacting frowning he's
surprised by this if it's possible if
all the rooks disappear and that end
game is a draw
then ferrugia has just worked out
everything perfectly but it's a big
gamble king and pawn end games assuming
the rooks get traded off now king and
pawn and games the hardest end game in
chess
and uh okay white's pawns on the king
side it's all about this right side of
the board now whether magnus can break
through there if he can he's winning
but uh
it's so hard to judge
i mean this is partly calculation partly
just instinct magnus thinks it's winning
judging by his
facial expression and
okay white's king can't break through on
this left side of the board that's the
left side is going to get completely
blocked any time soon um so the king
goes the other way
and
i would hate this position as black it's
it's a two result game it can only be a
white win or a draw but for roger he's
going to have to find the perfect setup
for black in order to draw this one just
judging by the evaluation bar it should
be a draw with best play but black is
cramped if you look in the center on the
e file white has a bit more space with
his pawn there meaning that he has the
advantage in the same game
but this is one of the ones that we can
work out there's a definite objective
result here if both plays play perfectly
which is a draw but objectives are kind
of impractical terms
so difficult so unpleasant to
defend yeah definitely
especially with all that lack of space
and working out how many extra porn
moves white has
oh
anxious stuff here in the
between magnus and
yeah
you do have uh mahdi cheering for
alireza fruga he's gonna need it
because he is fighting for his life in
this game and uh in the match if this is
a draw we will see blitz tie breaks
between rhinos and other rest of russia
and i think the whole world is hoping
for that
these two amazing uh
blitz players
yeah i'm kind of hoping for it to go to
armageddon
because then i don't know i don't i
honestly don't know who's gonna win you
know
i guess the player who has the white
pieces who has the extra time is just
going to
nail it but who knows
and uh meanwhile black has five minutes
here and it's a crucial decision for for
roger does he allow the white king to
continue stepping into the uh up the
board into the black half or does he
prevent that
you've got to be really careful how you
commit your pawns in these end games he
just
keeps the tension just moves the black
king across
and now if i were magnus i would be
moving that white king to the edge of
the board it doesn't look great but
at least once the king is there you can
throw pawns forward
you're more flexible i'm just worried
that if white's king doesn't take the
opportunity to step forward now it might
not get a second chance
so it's now or never
might be a draw anyway but
we'll see
magnus how does he want to win the same
game one thing that surprises me is that
magnus frowned so much and then kind of
was shocked
but it does
look like it should be a draw i mean
black doesn't have any weaknesses
despite what's extra space in the middle
of the board
is it a sign magnus is feeling confident
in the game that that facial reaction
either that or maybe
he just assumed that this was a win and
kind of wrote it off and uh now he's
having to calculate he's realizing it's
not so simple
simon you have uh thoughts here maybe
you should have been more patient david
yeah you know maybe maybe you've got
that to teach magnus you know from the
course it's not just
magnus teaching you maybe you know if
he'd have just taken his time a little
bit more he could have had the second
weakness on the king's side already i
mean of course he's pushing for the win
here with his active king more space and
the pawn breaks but black is very solid
black sh probably should be holding this
one
um we're also hearing i i you know just
to give you an update on the other big
match which is gonna you know uh if this
is a draw and prague wins for example
well that that's gonna lead to probably
the the most exciting match tomorrow
right uh and it seems like prague is a
little bit better in his game but the
barn that one yeah yeah all the way on
prague side black side which is probably
a good sign for the entertainment of you
know leaving it to the last day we we
kind of all won it on the last day
really absolutely last day i mean if
prague just wins this next wins this
game he gets at least one point he will
have a chance tomorrow against magnus
yep
yeah i mean if he beats magnus he'll
even if magnus wins this game he'll
catch up
if matt just doesn't win this game
prague wins tomorrow against magnus
he'll leapfrog him win the tournament
what a big game this is um i looked over
as well dude is playing some weird stuff
so
uh punishing him
yep
oh which is good for the tournament yeah
i see two tie breaks
what do you think
there was a tie break between
uh pragnanda and duda well i'm thinking
is it's a great way to spend saturday
you know
i'm i think that i mean
the energy seems to be with prague after
he held that after he held that ending
you know it seems to be on his side a
little bit and um
yeah yeah i mean i just can't wait till
tomorrow as well prague vs magnus
everyone remember that is the big one
tomorrow make sure you all come and
watch that it's going to be fantastic at
your alarms yeah i mean if prague wins
that and wins the whole thing
i mean that will be
news around the world won't it in the
chess community yeah maybe yeah
ginormous beyond i mean in india he'll
yeah he's already a celebrity he's
already a hero but yeah and so be
massive and if farouza wins this
encounter say in the tie breaks because
i don't think he's going to do it
here at all
then it will be anyone's game yeah if he
wins the tiebreaks yeah he will be tied
no magnus will be up by one point only
yeah two valley reservoirs
wow what uh finish it's gonna be uh we
have to admit we're kind of hoping
magnus won't win this game just for the
excitement in the tournament on that
final day
but of course the best man has to win
yeah and meanwhile heartbreak for neiman
fans he has fallen to defeat so still
not off the scoreboard uh iranian just
he's got a great game now he got a feel
for him because he just get he's always
he's so close he wins the first game
he's a great player he's going to be one
of the best in the world it's just a
tough week yeah it's you know it's
really sad and he's not cashing in at
the moment so maybe maybe one of the
other guys can buy zubritz today you
know
and
well i mean i i think black is holding
this now pretty pretty well i don't see
why the only way white's going to win
this is if he creates a weigh-in for his
king you you can't win this unless you
get your king into the position or maybe
get a pass pawn but
i just can't see any way that that white
can do this so he's trying a pawn push
he's trying to make some weaknesses in
black's position but
i think black is so far
remaining very solid at the moment i
mean but if black just simply blocks it
off by making this move
is there's no way in that draw total
white's king will never ever step beyond
the fourth rank now no matter what you
do if you capture a pawn you step your
white pawn forward it's just all blocked
i think i just have a feeling magnus
when the rooks came off he assumed that
the white king could go to the left side
of the board and break in there but
maybe he just forgot that this pawn
structure now that we see on the left
completely shuts it down so even if the
white king does a journey that left side
is blocked
i just have a feeling he assumed he
could get through on that flank but here
we go we will see a draw any moment now
the position is going to be completely
blocked
nothing else to play for the kings can't
get through and this is the lego move i
was talking about when someone pushes
their pawn you move their pawn next to
it so yeah i mean this is yeah you can
play for 100 moves here but
it's going to be a draw anyway and there
we go
tie breaks it's a draw
yay we will see blitz tie breaks between
these two speed demons magnus carlsen
and ali reza furuja
that will start five minutes after the
final game in round four is finished and
that game is uh prague against duda
first of all we're gonna